thank you Rocky well no matter how well
you know someone do you ever really know
what to give them for the holidays
well-intentioned as we are there are all
kinds of ways to botch gift giving but
if you know where to look you can be a
top-notch Gift Giver here's the story
Brittany Levine is a style and shopping
expert her advice to win at gift giving
this year let the receipt decide with
Snappy a new gifting platform Snappy is
an all-in-one gifting platform that is
really about the recipient picks
experience so the fabulous gift options
and when you're gifting it you can make
sure that your recipient all you need is
their loan number or email address and
once that the person gets it they can
choose from everything in that
collection so you know they're getting
exactly what they want and there will be
no returns or no duplicates this season
it's so simple to use Levine also says
to be aware of return policies this year
I always like to make sure that we all
know that all the stores are really
cracking down on holiday gift return
policies this year so I like to know to
be sure that we're always on top of
getting that right gift for everyone on
your list especially now for more info
visit snappygifts.com